now i would like to take all the
participants here through the program
resources and also other steps to
register themselves on the program page
so first of all i just like to introduce
myself i am sonalikari and i am the
omixlogic community manager and i'm
responsible for the daily interaction
with thousands of users that are a part
of a community that is managed by fine
powder
so uh for the different parts of the
sessions that dr mohit uh explained we
will leverage omix logic resources that
you can use to learn about precision
medicine we will explore the
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments our cloud-based analytical
server where you can analyze large or
mixed data and
visualize results the omixlogic code
playground will help you practice coding
in r and python and as well as
repositories of project examples are
some of the things that we're going to
explore these methods which we discussed
will include hands-on exercises on the
tbi info platform which provides a
simple and intuitive user interface for
processing analyzing and machine
learning methods for multi-omics data
and throughout the course you will be
given the directions
to access the tbi info platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of rna-seq data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections in this
multi-omics platform
and behind many of the methods are
scripts written in popular coding
languages such as r and python and these
are also explained in tutorials that you
will access to from by being a part of
this precision medicine program so from
visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis and hypothesis
testing
at the end of the program participants
will receive the certification of
participation and also registering for
the program now you will get the access
to the limited scholarship seats that we
have
that would enable up to 50 off on the
program registration i will shortly take
you through the program page and explain
uh the steps to register yourself for
the program
also i will take you through our social
media handles which you can join and
become a part of our bioinformatics
community in these social media handles
we keep sharing about recent trends in
research training material to learn and
get hands-on practical skills for these
trends updates about omixlogic learn
portal and also the t bioinfo server
also we share job posts for those who
complete the omixlogic training and are
ready to apply their knowledge to
resolve the real world problems
so i'll just quickly go to the amex
logic learn portal now and take you all
through the program page and let you
know how you can register yourself
for the program
so once again we are back on the omexage
learn portal the link is in the
chat
yes now please make sure that you have
signed up already and have an account as
record explained and have uh updated
your profile now let's go directly to
the program page and see how you can
register yourself for the program
so on the program page you will find all
the information if you have any
questions uh still if you still have any
questions about any of the topics that
would be covered you can go through the
syllabus here on the program page and if
you install a little bit more you will
find three different levels which are
beginner intermediate and advanced these
levels are actually referred to the
number of days that the participant will
have access to so in the beginner level
you are going to have the access to the
program for 45 days and in the
intermediate level you have an access to
the program for 16 days where you will
also be able to come up with a research
proposal that you can further work on in
the research fellowship program and in
the advanced level you will get the
access for 90 days where you can work on
your research project as well along with
the precision medicine training so that
is the difference between beginner
intermediate and advanced level and also
in the intermediate and advanced level
you will get the access to a one-on-one
expert sessions and
24 7 mentor support in the advanced
level you also have an option for
certificate of excellence as you also be
a part of the research fellowship
program
now it's up to you how for how many days
you want to enroll for the program
and it's very simple to register
yourself we just need to click on the
select option button for whichever
subscription level you would like to
enroll yourself for and then just
proceed uh with the registration
[Music]
also uh here on the program page itself
we have listed some program courses and
project libraries that you will have an
access to as a part of this pro
program and also you are supposed to go
through these resources so as dr mohick
explained that we have a bunch of
example projects that you will be going
through and learn from them about how
precision medicine could actually be
applied so these are the resources that
you can go through and learn from and
after a successful completion of the
program you will be uh getting a
certificate of completion and also a
certificate of excellence as a part of
the advanced level of subscription that
i already explained
now i want to share with you some of our
social media handles so that you can
stay updated with all the updates and
all the training programs that we would
be having and also be updated about a
job post that we keep on posting on our
social media handles so our presence is
there on youtube i'll share the link in
the chat as well
and do join our community on youtube so
that uh you stay connected with us uh
and um watch the videos that we keep
posting about different uh types of
specialization tracks and also the
training programs and then we are also
there on facebook by the name of buying
biotech so you can follow us on facebook
as well if you are there and uh now
comes the very important groups on
linkedin
so i'll just share the group of linkedin
channel as well in the
chat box
so we have a page on linkedin by the
name of omixlogic and we also have a
group where we have exports as well and
we keep on posting about the updates and
also the resources that you that you can
leverage from
this is the uh page that is comics logic
for which i have shared the link in the
chat and the group's name on linkedin
for omixlogic is machine learning
biomedical data mining and high
throughput data analysis
so you're most welcome to join our bio
informatics community community and
leverage the resources and also are the
experts who are a part of a community
so that was all that i wanted to discuss
with all of you today and i see we have
a question that persia has already
answered that's great so do we have any
other questions please you can put them
in the chat box
[Music]
so like i don't see any more questions
and i'd like to thank everyone for
joining today's session we will also be
sharing the session video recording all
right so if we
yes sir so if you have no more questions
i think we can end the session and uh
before we end today's session i just
like to put our email address that is
marketing added on sargent.com please
feel free to reach out to us uh for any
questions and we'll be happy to help and
uh while enrolling if you face any any
uh technical issue please feel free to
reach out to spa she will help you
become a part of the program and get
started with your training and research
in precision medicine
next we'll be meeting on june 14th so
thank you everyone for joining we'll
catch up on june 14th when the program
begins